what some themes and stories do you like
it seems like you're attracted to maybe
showing people's frailties and and and
may be unconventional characters or what
is it about yeah I think I think that's
uh I think that's true i really like
stories about you know I'm never really
good at answering these questions
because i right you know and I do lots
of rewrites for people and i right you
know sometimes I write horror movies and
sometimes I right action movies and you
know I love movies so there's a wide
interest but i will say that i tend to
always go down to an intimate story
about two or three people you know about
relationships and the inner workings of
relationships of people that are known
each other for a long time how that all
plays out i tend to really like that
kind of stuff um the relationship
between my character and Martin stars
character and six month rule you know
they go back years and i love the
subtleties of people that are used to
each other and there's also a great
relationship in weather girl between the
brother and sister that are kind of my
favorite parts of that of like this you
don't have to tell the audience
everything that's happened before in
order for the audience to get this
dynamic I like that Brian and almost the
dynamic of two people that maybe they
irritate each other but you're working
out live without each other absolutely
their dentures always to get well that's
some of the most amusing stuff to me
ever you know I love that stuff uh you
know Casablanca is one of my favorite
films and like you look at the
relationship between you know the
Commandant or whatever the and and Rick
and they know each other for a long time
they don't agree with each other about
everything but they like each other
almost in spite of themselves and I
think that's that's a cool dynamic
you